bien mes chers amis mon cher jean
félicitations pour cette brillante
élection à cette vice-présidence mon
cher laurent monsieur le maire merci de
nous accueillir merci mon cher eric
également nous accueillir dans ce si
beau département
alors vous m'avez demandé de partager
avec vous ce que nous avons accompli
depuis 2014 avec notre groupe des
républicains que je préside au parlement
européen merci pour cette opportunité
mon cher laurent et pour cette confiance
ce groupe et c'est d'actualité
aujourd'hui est la véritable équipe de
france comme j'aime la nommer des
eurodéputés les républicains membres de
la première force politique en europe le
ppe et nous aurons le plaisir
d'accueillir tout à l'heure dans la
matinée son président joseph daul nous
avons travaillé pour une france forte
dans une europe respecté dans le monde
en remportant de nombreux combats
c'est sans combats gagnés au service des
français que vous pouvez d'ailleurs
retrouver sur vos chaises dans notre
brochure de bilan un bilan qui vous
permettra de mieux saisir l'importance
d'avoir des députés utile pour défendre
efficacement les intérêts de notre pays
l' influence française au parlement
européen est déterminante pour que notre
pays pèse sur les décisions européennes
et face à l' isolement progressif et
jose insisté sur ce monde emmanuel
macron qui donne des leçons à tout le
monde en europe et vous avez eu raison
de le rappeler monsieur le maire les
républicains doivent avoir une voix que
l'on entend que l'on écoute et surtout
que l'on respecte mes chers amis face à
nous nous avons un emmanuel macron qui
tel un apiculteur traitance à rouge
il enfile son masque et surtout nous
enfume il propose une robe du miel une
europe du rêve n'est pas une europe de
l'action et surtout des résultats
concrets il se veut le capitaine d'un
navire sans câble venant d'un port sans
attache avec une stratégie courant
toujours vers plus de fédéralisme plus
de technocratie et surtout moins de
démocratie
et lorsque l'on parle de démocratie
justement
force est de constater qu emmanuel
macron n'en connaît pas la définition
ils tentent de passer en force sur la
scène européenne comme il le fait en
france
en témoigne sa volonté d'en finir avec
le processus démocratique d'élection du
président de la commission en fonction
du résultat des élections
et lorsqu'il a tenté de faire valider
cela auprès des autres chefs d'état il a
subi un échec cuisant
un autre échec les listes
transnationales
nous avons largement rejetée avec mes
collègues au parlement européen ce
gadget fédéraliste est inutile et qui
d'ailleurs a été rejeté la semaine
dernière par le conseil constitutionnel
grâce à un excellent travail de
guillaume larrivé et de constance le
grip qu'on peut applaudir en réalité mes
chers amis
emmanuel macron est seul en europe
et comme je lui ai dit au parlement à
strasbourg son mouvement va plus appelé
en marche
mais en marge en marge des décisions et
surtout en marge des résultats et nous
ne l'avons pas attendu pour travailler
efficacement vous allez le voir au
travers du bilan pour la france en
europe
ce n'est pas parce qu'on agite le
drapeau européen que l'on fait avancer
l'europe et ce n'est pas non plus parce
que l'on organise des consultations
financé par la machine gouvernementale
est clairement au service dans marche
que l'on répond préoccupations réelles
de nos compatriotes en digne hériter de
françois hollande emmanuel macron se
veut le maître de la communication mais
nous allons démontrer que nous sommes
les seuls à maîtriser l'action au niveau
européen depuis 2014 nous avons obtenu
des résultats tangibles
avec un credo celui de l'europe qui nous
protège et qui se protège nous sommes le
seul parti à pouvoir revendiquer un
bilan clair certes vous allez me dire on
n'est jamais élu sur un bilan mais vaut
mieux en avoir un face surtout face aux
socialistes qui sont inexistants et qui
ne compte plus et bien entendu face aux
extrêmes qu'ils font à bruxelles et à
strasbourg
lorsqu'ils sont là linverse de ce qu'il
prône sur les plateaux de télé à paris
c'est donc d'abord en faisant le point
sur notre bilan que nous pourrons
sereinement tous ensemble mener les
combats sur les priorités claires plus
de sécurité
une meilleure protection de nos
frontières une préférence donnée à nos
entreprises françaises et européennes
pour les commandes publiques et enfin
une véritable stratégie commerciale et
diplomatique dans un monde si instable
l'europe est un levier de puissance pour
la france à condition que son action ait
plus vite et surtout plus fort
nous avons besoin de l'europe mais pas
de n'importe quelle europe
alors portons cette voie réaliste
pragmatique offensive pour redonner
envie d'une europe qui se protège et qui
nous protège vraiment alors pour évoquer
mes chers amis maintenant dans le détail
les actions que nous menons pour
l'industrie nos entreprises l'innovation
l'agriculture et la pêche
je vous propose d'accueillir et
d'applaudir pour cette première partie
de la table ronde
anne sander geoffroy didier françoise
grosse tête
alain cadet et nous rejoindrons tout à
l'heure parce que comme c'est les aléas
du direct nous sommes obligés de tenir
compte du retard de certains avions nous
accueillerons également philippe juvin
michel dantin et angélique delahaye qui
son nom véritable spécialiste dans
domaine agricole
alors nous allons vous parler ici de nos
actions pour une europe qui protège ses
agriculteurs qui défend son industrie
qui agit pour ces entreprises en matière
d'eau ni d'innovation alors marché and
and toi qui es notre député d'alsace
avec qui nous défendons ardemment
d'ailleurs le siège du parlement
européen à strasbourg
tu t'es impliqué sur des dossiers
concrets comme la freins des frais
d'itinérance téléphonique ce qu'on
appelle vulgairement le roaming en
europe l'initiative europe pour l'emploi
des jeunes ou encore la formation
professionnelle alors en trois quatre
minutes est ce que tu pourrais nous dira
un petit peu plus de ce bilan que tu as
menée au sein du parlement européen
bonjour à tous je suis ravi d'être là
avec vous à menton aujourd'hui
d'habitude quand on parle d'europe c'est
plus souvent à strasbourg mais c'est
vrai il n'ya pas que strasbourg qui a
des sujets
européen on est en région frontalière
ici donc vraiment contente de passer ce
moment avec vous l'europe pour laquelle
je me suis battu et je continue à me
battre c'est pour une europe concrète
une europe concrète ça veut dire une
europe qui met qui a mis qui a mis fin
aux frais d'itinérance
vous savez c'est les surcoûts que vous
payez comme vous utilisez votre
téléphone portable dans un autre pays
européen
eh bien nous vous l'avons promis pendant
notre campagne de 2014 et nous l'avons
fait en 2017
il n'y a plus de roaming plus de freins
d'itinérance aujourd'hui ça veut dire
que lorsque vous passer la frontière
pour aller en italie ou pour aller dans
un autre pays européen
lorsque des jeunes vont faire des études
pendant quelques semaines à l'étranger
est bien là aussi il n'y a plus de coup
les républicains se battent au parlement
européen pour une europe concrète et une
europe qui s'engagent dans les
territoires et qui les accompagnent dans
la lutte contre la fracture numérique
parce que contrairement à emmanuel
macron nous n'avons pas délaisser ni les
zones rurales
ni les territoires français ces zones
rurales qui sont importantes en france
voilà pourquoi nous avons défendu une
europe là aussi qui investit dans les
territoires qui financent l'arrivée de
la de la fibre optique dans un certain
nombre de territoires et surtout moi je
me suis battu pour un programme qui
s'appelle le wifi gratuit
et là c'est l'union européenne et bien
qui va financer pour les communes des
bornes de vie de wifi gratuit alors
mesdames et messieurs les maires les
présidents d'intercommunalités s'il y en
a dans la salle eh bien allez vous
inscrire sur le site et postuler pour
pouvoir bénéficier de ce programme
voilà ce qu'a était partie en tout cas
de mon combat c'est le marché numérique
dans les territoires pour que les
entreprises puissent continuer à
investir dans ce qui fait la richesse de
la france
merci beaucoup anne
françoise grossetête alors françoise
c'est un des piliers de cette délégation
c'est certainement celle qui est la plus
grande expérience c'est la
vice-présidente également du groupe du
ppe au parlement européen aux côtés de
manfred weber
notre présidence alors françoise tu as
parlé tu as porté au parlement un
dossier crucial récemment sur le fonds
européen pour l'industrie de la défense
qui sera une réalisation concrète de
l'europe et de la défense nous avons
également beaucoup travaillé sur la
politique spatiale re européenne qui est
un des fleurons de notre industrie et tu
pourras peut-être nous en dire un mot
ici te reste quelques instants je
connais tu en engageant également sur
les thématiques de la santé du numérique
françoise la parole est à toi merci
beaucoup franck alors c'est vrai que je
suis très heureuse de me retrouver ici
parce que je suis dans ma
circonscription
même si je viens du nord de cette grande
circonscription du sud-est et ça m'a
permis déjà depuis deux jours de
rencontrer un certain nombre d'acteurs
économiques de cette circonscription et
de cette région du sud de la france
alors sur la défense ici plus que jamais
on comprend la nécessité de protéger nos
concitoyens d'assurer lors c'est leur
sécurité et leur défense est bien au
parlement européen nous avons vécu un
moment particulièrement historique
puisque c'est la première fois que nous
avons voté un premier texte législatif
concernant l'europe de la défense il ya
encore deux ans ne pouvait pas parler
d'europe de la défense mais le bric site
d'une part là les propos de donald trump
concernant l'union européenne qui devait
assumer seul
et puis le contexte malheureusement
international extrêmement instable font
que l'union européenne a compris qu'il
fallait absolument assurer la défense et
la sécurité de nos concitoyens
et c'est ainsi que nous avons décidé de
créer un fonds européen pour la défense
pour lequel j'ai été rapporteur et qui
va permettre de soutenir des projets des
projets pilotes et de développer
l'innovation et la compétitivité de
l'industrie de l'armement
et ils n'étaient pas il n'est pas
favorable pour l'union européenne
d'avoir cent soixante dix huit armes
différentes
alors que les états unis n'ont que 30 et
tout ceci est fait pour assurer
l'autonomie stratégique de l'union
européenne et pour assurer cette
autonomie stratégique il faut aussi
franck l'a dit il faut aussi développer
un accès indépendant à l'espace et
soutenir nos programmes copernic
copernicus et galileo tu as parlé franck
de la santé oui c'est vrai je me suis
engagé depuis très nombreuses années sur
la politique de santé dans l'union
européenne et nous avons décidé dans
notre groupe du parti populaire européen
de porter une action particulière sur la
lutte contre le cancer
aucun citoyen européen n'est n'est à
l'abri de prêt ou de moins de cette
maladie et nous avons décidé de faire de
cette lutte contre le cancer
un de nos axes prioritaires et en
insistant particulièrement sur les
cancers pédiatriques pour lesquelles
malheureusement nous manquons
cruellement de thérapie enfin je
parlerai et se termine de la stratégie
de l'union européenne pour
l'intelligence artificielle avec des
applications non seulement dans le
domaine de la santé dans le domaine du
transport dans le domaine de
l'agriculture dans le domaine de la
domotique des axes qui vont permettre
d'augmenter les investissements
et puis de préparer les changements
socio économiques qui vont être provoqué
par l'intelligence informatique
nous sommes là effectivement pour
accompagner cette révolution que nous
vivons dans notre société la révolution
du numérique
et là aussi protéger les citoyens
européens
merci françoise alors je vais passer
maintenant la parole à notre dernière
recrue puisqu'il a pris la succession de
constance le grip quand elle a été élue
députée je veux parler bonjour philippe
vous voyez la tribune se remplit petit à
petit c'est parfait nous sommes au
complet
la récente recrue de notre délégation je
parlais bien sûr de geoffroy didier qui
il a pris je dois vous dire son mandat
européen à bras le corps et je voulais
le remercier ici alors nous avons
travaillé ensemble tu le sais mon cher
geoffroy pour lutter contre la
concurrence déloyale dans le secteur
routier européen
tu t'es impliqué sur la révision du
droit d'auteur au niveau européen qui
d'ailleurs sera votée dès la semaine
prochaine à strasbourg et tu as été
récemment nommé rapporteur sur le projet
de directive sur les recours collectifs
donc cela tous ces sujets concernent
directement les consommateurs
tu pourras nous en dira davantage la
parole est à toi mon cher geoffrey merci
franck lorsque je suis devenue députée
au parlement européen il ya mieux si
moins de six mois
je vous avoue que j'ai été frappé par la
complexité hallucinante de la tuyauterie
de cette machinerie législatives
administratives réglementaires qui
dessert cette belle idée qu'est l'europe
et qui est malheureusement à la hauteur
de sa légende
mais ce que j'ai vite compris c'est que
bien utiliser l'europe pouvait être un
immense instrument de pouvoir et ce que
nous vous proposons c'est précisément
d'utiliser cet instrument de pouvoir
qu'est l'europe pour mieux se protéger
nous les français parce que nous avons
plus que jamais besoin de nous protéger
face à une mondialisation sans visage
sans limites sans frontières sans âme
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
effectivement mon cher franck je me suis
battu pour devenir le rapporteur d'un
projet de directive qui vous permettra
d'ici quelques mois vous comme
consommateur comme client comme
internautes comme voyageurs exercer
ensemble des recours judiciaires contre
eux contre toutes ces grandes
entreprises aussi puissante que des
états et qui abusent de leur pouvoir
vous ne pouvez pas le faire seul parce
que seul ça coûte trop cher seuls ces
condamnés à l'échec mais vous pourrez
désormais exercer ses recours en justice
ensemble et c'est la preuve que l'europe
devient plus protectrice parce que
l'europe elle est déjà et roule on ne
dit pas suffisamment
protectrice regardez par exemple quand
l'entreprise facebook pillent vos
données personnelles violent la loi
devant qui le pdg de facebook mark
zuckerberg se sentent ils contraints de
venir s'expliquer devant le congrès
américain
parce que c'est son pays et devant le
parlement européen
parce qu'il a bien compris que nous
étions aussi une force capable de
résister à toutes ces grandes
entreprises
donc je suis convaincu que dans les
prochains mois si nous sommes déterminés
si nous sommes unis si nous sommes
offensif
nous pouvons faire de l'europe un
bouclier nous pouvons faire de l'europe
cette ceinture de sécurité qui nous
aidera à mieux traverser les turbulences
de cette mondialisation sauvage
donc je vous le dis en conclusion ne
vous laissez pas impressionner par tous
ces commentateurs qui n'ont aucun
intérêt à ce que nous réussissions à
droite
ne vous laissez pas impressionner par
tous ces commentateurs qui accuse
laurent wauquiez de courir après le
front national mais que ça ne gêne pas
de porter au pinacle la petite-fille de
marine le pen
nous sommes patriote nous sommes
patriotes et nous sommes européens
et c'est bien parce que nous sommes
européens aussi et c'est bien parce que
nous sommes patriotes avant tout que
nous allons utiliser pendant cette
campagne et au delà l'europe pour mieux
protéger les français je vous remercie
merci beaucoup et j'en profite pour
accueillir christian jacob le président
du groupe à l'assemblée nationale qui
est la question
on peut l'applaudir lui aussi à lui fait
un travail remarquable
[Applaudissements]
je dois dire grâce à laurent wauquiez
que la commission interparlementaire qui
l'a mise en place est une commission
extraordinaire avec lequel avec
christian et avec bruno votre avis
retailleau nous définissons ensemble au
quotidien une véritable ligne des
républicains sur tous les sujets
européens
philippe tu viens d'arriver je te prends
un show la parole est à toi au moment où
on parle de plus en plus des fameux
gaffard philippe je voudrais que tu nous
éclaire sur l'action de l'europe en
matière de protection nos acteurs
européens face aux plates formes en
ligne et je voudrais également si tu le
souhaites évoqué des actions pour
l'émergence d'un véritable marché unique
numérique et plus largement philippe je
pense que tu pourrais nous exposer
brièvement ta vision du marché intérieur
on nous démontrons bien sûr tous ces
apports et son intérêt pour nos
concitoyens comme ça en trois minutes
philippe bond tout d'abord je dois
m'excuser de ce retard mais c'est dû à
un règlement européen c'est à dire que
l'avion qui venait du dehors de l'espace
schengen devait être fouillé et l'équipe
qui devaient fouiller l'avion n'était
pas l'arrêt voyez ce à cause de l'europe
que nous sommes en retard
bon plus sérieusement plus sérieusement
nous aux républicains traditionnellement
notre famille politique
nous avons toujours été une famille
politique lucide sur les questions
européennes
c'est à dire qu'on en connaît les
défauts et on en connaît les qualités à
l'union européenne
il faut pas tomber dans les deux mots m
ax deux discours celui d'emmanuel macro
on a l'impression que tout va bien et
celui de marine le pen où on a
l'impression que tout va mal parce que
en matière européenne
on raconte souvent beaucoup de bêtises
et je faisais une discussion récemment
avec un député du front national qui me
disait en europe
il ya plein de fonctionnaires c'est un
truc technocratique qui marchent pas et
je lui ai dit mais vous n'êtes pas au
courant il ya moins de fonctionnaires
dans toute l'union européenne qu'à la
seule ville de paris
la municipalité de madame hidalgo a plus
de fonctionnaires or vous ne direz c'est
madame hidalgo j'entends bien que dans
toute l'union européenne
c'est vous dire que quand on parle
questions européennes
il faut le faire à bon escient alors
l'europe
il ya des endroits où ça marche pas bien
la question de l'immigration est
évidente
un vrai problème il ya aussi des choses
qui fonctionnent et nous avons décidé en
europe comme vous le savez de construire
ce qu'on appelle un grand marché unique
qui englobe les 28 états demain 27 qui
font que les pme françaises qui fabrique
des produits peuvent les vendre partout
n'ont pas non pas parce qu'il n'y a pas
de barrières douanières pas seulement
mais parce que nous votons des lois qui
rendent on commune les règles de
distribution de vente et de protection
du consommateur et donc il faut que nous
soyons très vigilants à cette idée que
nous avons besoin de l'union européenne
pour nos pme pourquoi parce que nos pme
ont plus intérêt à avoir un marché de
500 millions d'européens que 67 millions
de français et d'ailleurs les
britanniques qui vont sortir du marché
unique font tout pour y rester
les britanniques sont des gens très très
malin et ils disent je veux sortir de
l'union européenne mais je restais dans
le marché unique ces dernières qu'il ya
une raison en réalité je veux aussi que
vous soyez très tranquille sur la
question du patriotisme
parce que les gens du fond du front
national vous dites vous dise ah mais si
vous êtes européen
vous n'êtes pas patriote mais c'est une
aberration c'est justement parce que
vous êtes patriotes justement parce que
vous êtes patriotes que vous êtes
européen parce que vous avez compris que
la france avait besoin d'un véhicule de
puissance pour continuer à parler au
monde et l'union européenne ça sert à ça
et donc nous européens nous avons cette
ambition là et nous avons l'ambition de
faire ce qui ne fonctionne plus depuis
notre ami françois hollande le fameux
monsieur de la rue du cirque avec son
scooter
eh bien nous avons cette ambition de
faire en sorte que la france de nouveaux
pèse dans le débat européen
et c'est un des grands sujets de cette
élection européenne
faire en sorte que deux nouveaux dans
les sphères de décisions européennes
nous posions jean terminée par une
anecdote quand vous lisez le livre
d'alain peyrefitte alain peyrefitte
c'était le porte parole du général de
gaulle
du gouvernement et alain peyrefitte
raconte une anecdote dans ses mémoires
un moment ils demandent en général de
gaulle mon général
croyez vous que la france existera
toujours et là le général de gaulle
réfléchit quelques secondes comme quoi
la réponse n'est pas évidente et il dit
probablement probablement à condition
que la france s'en donne les moyens
c'est ça l'union européenne c'est le
moyen pour la france de continuer à
exister dans le concert mondial
merci philippe on va passer maintenant
mais que notre trio magique concernant
deux secteurs essentiels pour la france
je veux parler bien entendu de
l'agriculture et de la pêche avec michel
dantin angeli gueulait et alain cadet
alors me michel avec angélique vous est
sans aucun doute les plus grands
spécialistes des enjeux agricoles
européens
son implication je crois pour défendre
nos agriculteurs est reconnu par tous et
tu pourrais aujourd'hui nous parler
aujourd'hui des enjeux de concurrence
dans le secteur agricole mais aussi du
sujet précis qui concerne les droits de
plantation pour la vigne ou encore des
mécanismes de lutte contre les crises
agricoles comme le retrait volontaire de
la production michel la parole est à toi
parler d'agriculture s'est d'abord parlé
de notre alimentation
et si nous sommes tant attachés à une
alimentation de qualité avec notre
propre règle avec des aliments produits
sans ogm avec des aliments produits sans
hormones c'est parce que nous avons une
agriculture européenne et que nous la
défendons effectivement du fait de sa
surface
la france est la première puissance
intéressés par la question agricole et
nous avons trop longtemps nous les
français et les pays du sud
laisser dicter nos règles par les pays
d'europe du nord qui n'ont pas la même
appréhension sur un certain nombre de
sujets pour nous les latins un produit
de qualité c'est un produit qui a du
goût qu un produit qui est de la saveur
un produit qui a une odeur parce que
pour nous la limitation
la table est un lieu de fête un lieu de
convivialité
et se battre pour notre agriculture
défendre les droits de plantation pour
les viticulteurs défendre la capacité
d'exportation de notre génétique ou
renforcer le pouvoir des producteurs
dans la négociation vis-à-vis de la
grande distribution
c'est d'abord penser à l'intérêt du
consommateur européen cela l'europe nous
le permet parce que il nous elle nous
offre un marché dont bénéficient nos
agriculteurs trop souvent la presse nous
bassine aujourd'hui en nous montrant
uniquement ce qui ne va pas
l'importation de tomates du maroc parce
que nous avons signé des accords
l'importation de tel ou tel produit
mais nous sommes et nous restons les
premiers bénéficiaires de la politique
agricole commune
parce que nous vendons nos produits aux
autres pays européens
ce combat il faut le mener avec
acharnement
parce que c'est un enjeu pour la
ruralité également nos territoires qui
se sentant délaissé par la politique du
gouvernement actuel sont pourtant des
atouts économiques
nous devons nous battre pour maintenir
la valeur ajoutée dans les territoires
parce que c'est la valeur ajoutée qui
permettra de rémunérer les emplois c'est
ça le sens de l'engagement de la
bataille que nous menons au parlement
européen pour faire briller la france
merci michel angélique nous étions
récemment d'ailleurs en indre et loire
avec laurent il ya à peu près une
semaine pour tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
sur l'abandon par emmanuel macron de nos
agriculteurs et surtout de son double
discours comme dit le commissaire au
budget monsieur ho ting guerre entre
paris et bruxelles sur la pac et les
aspects budgétaires qui se négocie
actuellement alors pourrais tu nous dire
deux mots sur justement l'avenir de
cette politique agricole commune
d'abord bonjour à toutes et à tous je
suis ravi d'être à vos côtés aujourd'hui
le combat il est quotidien au parlement
européen geoffroy le disais tout à
l'heure
moi aussi j'ai été frappé par la
complexité de la machine mais une fois
qu'on a bien compris la machine
elle peut nous est effectivement
extrêmement utile et c'est ce à quoi
nous nous attachons régulièrement
concernant la politique agricole commune
moi j'étais à dire que la proposition
faite par le commissaire dans un
contexte budgétaire extrêmement
contraint me paraît à côté à côté des
enjeux est très loin des enjeux auxquels
l'agriculture doit répondre demain on
demande aux agriculteurs toujours plus
de contraintes
parce que la société attend d'eux des
produits de qualité des produits sans
ogm des produits de moins en moins
protégés par les pesticides et pour
autant le budget de l'europe baisse les
concernant simplement parce que la
contrainte budgétaire est faite est liée
à la sortie des britanniques
sauf que derrière tout ça il ya un
énorme tour de passe-passe auquel michel
et moi nous nous attachons de dénoncer
le montant le dernier budget 408
milliards d'euros le prochain 365 les
britanniques entre ce qu'il apportait à
la pac
est-ce qu'il recevait de la pax années
que 19 milliards le tour de passe-passe
et 24 milliards et on est en train de
nous demander de choisir entre deux
nouvelles politiques qu'il faut financer
100 m un euro de plus dans la caisse et
prendre 24 milliards à la politique
agricole commune pour financer ses
projets politiques nouvelles
d'immigration et de sécurité dont nous
avons aussi besoin
et bien ça c'est pas possible et c'est
pas admissible on peut pas demander à
choisir entre les agriculteurs et
l'immigration
et ça je m'y refuse
je terminerai mon propos parce que au
parlement aurait peint on n'a guère plus
de 2 minutes 30 en règle générale donc
je ne sais pas combien je suis homo
conseil national mais mais je dois être
à deux non non il était méchant juste
pour dire que la politique agricole
commune
elle a un volet alimentation comme l'a
souligné michel tout à l'heure nous y
sommes tous attachés
mais là aussi un volet environnement et
au moment où à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat
on va vous questionner sur la question
de l'article 1 de la constitution pour y
mettre l'environnement
soyons là aussi une fois de plus
extrêmement prudent d'où le lien que tu
soulignait tout à l'heure et l'intérêt
que laurent ait créé cette ce triptyque
entre le parlement européen
franck christian et puis bruno pour que
très en amont nous prenions des
positions claires de notre famille
politique pour les enjeux à venir et
l'agriculture est un enjeu fort tout
autant que l'environnement et je
m'attache de mon mandat de parlementaire
à lier systématiquement l'un et l'autre
pour ne plus les opposer merci angélique
voudrais saluer la présence d'eric
woerth qui vient de nous rejoindre ce
matin alors alain la parole est à toi
nous avons là le grand spécialiste de la
politique commune de la pêche
nous sommes fiers d'ailleurs d'avoir
deux délégations le seul président ppe
républicain de commissions
parlementaires c'est alain cadec tu
pourrais nous parler à l'un de tes
combats pour défendre ce secteur durable
pour nos pêcheurs et peut-être en
évoquant le grand débat récent sur
l'interdiction de la pêche électrique et
peut être de moi également sur l'
influence du mexique sur nos amis
pêcheurs
merci franck bonjour à tous je suis très
heureux d'être à menton aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'hier j'ai fait une
diagonale brest mentons pas faire plus
loin pour venir vous rejoindre
alors d'abord j'ai un petit cri du coeur
avoue vous transmettre au pas au
parlement européen
vous avez je dis bien vous avez nous
avons mais vous avez ici aux
républicains des députés qui portent nos
valeurs qui travaillent
contrairement à ce qu'on peut raconter
on dit n'importe quoi là dessus
les gens qui sont ici à cette table sans
épaisseur 1 par philippe juvin c'est
vrai nous fait remarquer non et je vous
invite à regarder les sites internet qui
nous flic régulièrement nous bossons
parlement européen je voulais le dire
aujourd'hui parce que c'est un port ya
même une application sur smartphone vous
pouvez voilà vous pouvez y aller
exactement
et puis je vous invite aussi à lire avec
intérêt tout ça parce que c'est un
résumé du boulot qu'on a pu faire
pendant tout son mandat
alors ce matin mois avec quelques-uns je
vois quelques amis là-bas dans la salle
je représente la mafia bretonne ce qui
n'a pas échappé que n'a pas échappé que
notre président de la république avait
considéré qu'il y avait une mafia
bretonne pourquoi pas après tout une
diaspora sûrement en tous les cas alors
on salue l'arrivée parmi nous je vois
pas de valérie pécresse
donc on salue valérie pécresse
[Applaudissements]
vas-y est jeune et je voudrais qu'on
salue également bernard acoyer qui est
là bas il a présidé ce conseil national
pendant très longtemps
voilà alors valérie côte aura fini je
continuerai non mais vas-y continu
continu et à user d'accord donc tu m'as
parlé du match ne me demandez pas deux
exemples précis c'est vrai pour certains
vous avez pu suivre les épisodes
concernant la pêche électrique certains
s'y sont intéressés quelque part l'un la
pêche électrique une pêche peu pratiqué
par les néerlandais notamment
c'est une pêche destructrices des trucs
tiges de l'or dans l'environnement mais
destructrice aussi de la ressource et
donc nous nous sommes battus et c'est
grâce grâce au ppe grâce à l'action de
là ont pu mener ensemble nous les
députés républicains que nous avons fait
rejeter ce principe de la pêche
électrique
c'est une victoire c'est un combat et
c'est une victoire et je pense qu'il
faut le rôle de dire et c'est une
victoire du ppe et c'est une victoire
des républicains pour le disent par
ailleurs
par ailleurs on travaille beaucoup en ce
moment ça a été évoqué par mes collègues
qui parlait de l'agriculture sur le
break site
vous imaginez bien que la pêche et d'un
est un des secteurs les plus impactés
par le break site pour l'accès aux eaux
eh bien nous y travaillons tous les
jours
n'est ce pas valérie tous les jours avec
michel barnier qui a en charge ce
dossier au niveau de la commission
européenne pour permettre à nos navires
de pouvoir toujours pêcher sur les côtes
britanniques
et ça c'est très compliqué nos amis
britanniques sont très compliquées mais
on y travaille au quotidien et on ne
lâche rien parce que nous les députés
européens de la délégation les
républicains on ne lâche rien il faut le
dire et je tiens à le dire aujourd'hui
alors la méditerranée puisque ici on est
au bord de la méditerranée en conclusion
pour une fois je suis à mon temps et je
parle du père mais bon on m'a dressé des
objectifs est quand même au parlement
européen mais c'est dommage mais pas
l'écran simplement dire que la
méditerranée n'est pas n'est pas en
reste qui a un plan de gestion qui est
en cours qui va participer à sauver la
méditerranée et qui va sauver la
méditerranée c'est l'europe qui va
sauver la méditerranée donc encore une
fois
oui mon cher julien on peut être
patriote est profondément européen
merci merci à alain je peux vous dire
que c'est quelqu'un qui a le punch et
qui défend ces dossiers avec un courage
et une abnégation hors du commun
voilà on peut que clôturera cette
première table ronde sur l'europe qui
nous protège et on va passer rapidement
donc à l'europe qui se protège et je
vais appeler nadine morano et rachida
dati
[Musique]
well et rachid art médical et là alors
le temps qu'elle se met en place
l'europe qui se protège c'est l'europe
qui protège à la fois ses concitoyens
mais également ces entreprises là encore
un certain nombre de réalisations ont
été faites et je crois que dans les deux
dernières années on a marqué la fin de
la naïveté européenne on a refusé le
statut d'économie de marché de la chine
on a révisé nos instruments de défense
commerciale je suis en train de finir un
rapport sur le filtrage des
investissements étrangers non pas sur
les investissements étrangers mais sur
les investissements étrange
bonjour agi d'art c'est à dire ceux qui
ne répondent pas une logique économique
mais logique politique mais il nous
reste une marge de progression énorme
parce que je dois vous le dire mes chers
amis nous sommes dans une guerre
commerciale confère l'attitude de
monsieur trump à notre égard
ou encore à l'égard des chinois et quand
on fait une guerre eh bien il faut
utiliser les mêmes armes que nos
concurrents
moi j'aime jouer nous sommes tous
ouverts aux républicains mais comme en
football avec les mêmes règles
si je fais un match de football qu'on
est à dix contre onze
qu'on a un arbitres qui sifflent
systématiquement contre nous qu'on n'a
pas de gardien
au mieux on fait match nul mais jamais
on peut gagner alors mes chers amis il y
aura deux thèmes essentiels pendant
cette campagne
d'abord la réciprocité parce que quand
tu es américains ouvrent leurs marchés
publics à 30% que les chinois ouvrent
leurs marchés à 0%
il est évident que l'europe ne peut pas
continuer à ouvrir ses marchés publics à
100% et encore et je sais que c'est un
sujet cher à mon ami christian jacob
il faudra sur certains secteurs comme le
font nos concurrents avoir une
préférence communautaire dans
l'aéronautique dans la défense chez nos
agriculteurs ou encore dans
l'aérospatiale je pense que là encore
c'est un des outils que nous devons
prendre dans la prochaine mandature
alors après avoir protégé ses
entreprises effectivement l'europe doit
projet pour protéger ses concitoyens est
donc là nous avons deux experts nadine
et ra sida
nadine
nous étions avec toi avec laurent hier à
la frontière alors sans tabou nous
vivions ensemble que l'europe n'a pas
anticipé le défi migratoire et ça ce
n'est que le début
je voudrais que tu nous parles de ton
implication sur ces dossiers évoqués
notamment nos relations avec l'afrique
toi qui étais récemment déplacement sur
ce continent tu pourrais aussi évoquer
la fin d'année ft qui doit guider
l'action européenne et notamment terme
de conditionnalité des aides
nadine la parole est à toi merci franck
merci à tous de votre présence à fait
chaud au coeur de voir une famille unie
rassemblée libre de débattre dans ses
idées libre d'agir qui marchent ensemble
vous êtes tous là et vous voulez que les
républicains gâte de masse et élections
européennes parce que c'est le prochain
défi que nous avons à relever
alors je vais vous parler d'un sujet qui
est très sensible parce qu'il concerne
l'humain parce qu'il concerne la
responsabilité de tous
je suis la seule députée française
membre de la délégation en charge des
relations avec le parlement panafricain
parce que nous avons un parlement
européen
mais il ya aussi un parlement
panafricain et nous travaillons de
concert parce que nous savons comme nous
l'avons vu avec laurent wauquiez hier
lorsque nous sommes allés avec le maire
de menton aux postes frontières voir ces
jeunes ces jeunes hommes seuls qui
arrive en majorité du continent africain
au péril de leur vie qui ont une
vingtaine d'années qui viennent chercher
meilleure vie un espoir
nous avons vu sur leur visage à la fois
l'espérance mais à la fois la
désespérance la rudesse de ce qu'ils ont
vécu et moi je le dis en sincérité
afrique
réveille-toi occupe toi de tes enfants
ne laisse pas risquer leur vie
l'union européenne verse l'union
européenne aide au développement de
l'afrique chaque année à hauteur de 17
milliards d'euros
nous avons des programmes de
développement avec l'afrique et pour
autant
depuis que je suis petit j'entends
l'afrique est un pays en voie de
développement
maintenant je suis grand mère et
j'entends l'afrique a encore des
problèmes de développement
elle sacrifie sa jeunesse 1,2 milliard
d'habitants
plus de 700 millions d'habitants qui ont
moins de 20 ans 60% de la population
nous devons aider au développement de
l'afrique et je me réjouis de voir que
les députés panafricain de tous les pays
des 53 états qui représentent cette
union africaine ont tenu une séance
plénière entière pour débattre de la
corruption dans les états africains
parce qu'ils savent que c'est un des
maux majeurs de la déstabilisation de la
pauvreté dans leur pays
il faut lutter contre cette corruption
il faut donner des aides en fonction de
la maîtrise de l'immigration
nous ne pouvons plus donner des aides
tant qu'il n'y a pas d'efforts sur
l'immigration nous ne pouvons plus
donner des aides tant que les états ne
prendront pas conscience qu'ils doivent
s'occuper de leur jeunesse nous devons
les aider ils devront ils devront faire
des efforts
nous ne pouvons pas accueillir tous ceux
qui arrivent et avec laurent nous
l'avons constaté les propositions de
monsieur macron font exactement l'un
vers ce il incite à l'immigration
illégale parce que je vous rappelle que
c'est de l'immigration illégale le en
même temps vouloir vouloir installer des
centres d'accueil pour les réfugiés dans
l'union européenne
mais dire en même temps pas en france
dire qu'il faudra accueillir des
réfugiés de l'aquarius mehdi en même
temps que l'aquarius
n'a pas vocation à l'est dans un des
ports français mais quand délivrera des
titres de séjour pour ceux qui arrivent
sur notre territoire
alors un seul mot pour terminer franck
merci il faut comprendre une chose ce
qui arrive de l'afrique subsaharienne
les pays pauvres leur niveau moyen de
revenus c'est à peu près 100 euros en
erythrée on nous avons vu des jeunes
d'erythrée hier 38 euros par mois s'ils
obtiennent le statut de réfugié en
france
ils ont droit au rsa s'ils obtiennent le
statut de réfugié en france ils ont
droit toutes les aides de la caf avec
rétroactivité de deux ans comment voulez
vous que ces jeunes qui espèrent gagner
x 6 leurs revenus n'espère pas venir en
france
alors les députés africains je voulus
dimon dit arrêtez de régulariser c'est
vous qui encouragent et l'immigration
illégale et nous dans les villages on se
cotise pour que les jeunes hommes
viennent en europe pour gagner de
l'argent et nous le renvoyer dans nos
pays c'est pas la solution
avec j'ai terminé c'est ma conclusion
avec laurent et avec mon amie rachida et
permettez moi de citer tous enfin peux
pas les citer mais de les évoquer mes
collègues députés européens avec
lesquels on a énormément bossé et une
pour lequel j'ai une affection
particulière vous le comprendrez
j'ai commencé ma vie politique j'avais
20 ans c'est michèle alliot marie est
donc michèle alliot marie c'est pour moi
un exemple et je la porte dans mon coeur
avec jean leonetti qui maintenant est
notre présidente du conseil national
simplement avec laurent wauquiez notre
vision et notre ligne politique
c'est évidemment d'avoir d'une maîtrise
de l'immigration et de faire en sorte
que nos relations internationales avec
le continent africain se développe dans
le risque dans un esprit d'humanité et
de responsabilité vive le rap et vive la
france
merci à vous merci
rachida rachida dati on sait rachida ton
application pour enfin porter au niveau
du parlement européen le débat sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme qui a été en
outre remarquable tu as fait voter
d'ailleurs ton rapport une large
majorité sur la prévention de la
radicalisation et je me souviens
d'ailleurs d'un déplacement avec toi
pour aller visiter le centre de
guantanamo
tu t'es impliqués pour responsabiliser
les géants du net dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme
tu pourras peut-être nous parlait
également de la peut-être nécessaire
refonte de l'espace schengen la parole
est à toi merci france je voulais
remercier nadine pour cet enthousiasme
qui est constant et compris au parlement
européen
et c'est comme ça qu'on fait avancer des
sujets européens moi je voulais vous
remercier toutes et tous d'être là
aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que ça démontre ça démontre
que vous avez envie qu'on se bat pour
nos idées
vous avez envie qu'on se bat pour la
réalité parce que souvent la presse vous
présente comme étant la france va bien
que finalement il n'y a pas d'opposition
et quand elles existent elles ne
seraient pas audible entré qu'à votre
présence démontre que nous pouvons être
audible et qui a de vraies difficultés
en france quand on voit pardon pour le
le schéma le paysage national violences
urbaines tous les jours attaque des
forces de l'ordre et des forces de
sécurité tous les jours fracture de la
société tous les jours
montée du communautarisme tous les jours
radicalisation tous les jours tout ça
s'est passé sous le tapis ce sont nos
combats nos combats au niveau national
mais ce sont aussi nos combats au niveau
européen au parlement européen et veut
france vient de le dire et je
j'abonde dans le sens de ce que vient
dire nadine et le sujet africain est une
un sujet réel puisqu'on est en train de
débattre au niveau européen
mais si l'afrique ne prend pas ses
responsabilités ça ne servira à rien
comme le dernier accord obtenu au sommet
européen d'hier qui est un accord qui ne
servira à rien comme la loi asie
l'immigration déjà voté
et je parle en présence d'eric ciotti
qui est ici qui s'est battu pour
effectivement faire passer nos idées en
parlement pour lutter efficacement
contre cette immigration illégale s'est
clos a été passé cette loi n'est pas à
la hauteur des enjeux
quand je vois je parlais a ensuite de la
radicalisation la radicalisation ne faut
pas l'oublier ça existe depuis un
certain nombre d'années on nous a dit
que c'était un problème social
ce n'est pas un problème social c'est un
problème criminelle aujourd'hui la
radicalisation est présente partout sur
le territoire national
alors c'est vrai que au parlement
européen on apporter un combat depuis
maintenant plus de cinq ans et on l'a
obtenu
c'est la responsabilité pénale des
géants du net il ya deux voies de
radicalisation en france les prisons et
on voit et on a vu encore le malaise en
prison
rien n'est fait pour les prisons rien
n'est fait pour les prisons et nous
avons une montée du communautarisme mais
aussi de la radicalisation qui se fait
majoritairement en prison l'autre voie
de radicalisation c'est internet
et évidemment nous avons demandé puisque
internet dit on ne peut rien faire
moi j'ai souhaité qu'il soit mis en
cause en cas de deux crimes perpétrés
par des individus radicalisés ce qui est
le cas dans 100% des cas qu'ils puissent
être attrait et responsables ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'un individus
radicalisés sur le net
bassil eux les géants du net n'ont pas
fait ce qu'il fallait pour essayer de
supprimer des comptes empêcher cette
apologie de la haine de la barbarie et
du crime et bien qu'il soit considéré
comme complice
de ces individus radicalisés nous avons
obtenu cette mesure elle a commencé à
être appliquée en angleterre en
allemagne dans d'autres pays européens
la france on est encore à la traîne
au départ on nous avait dit que c'était
une atteinte à la liberté d'expression
moi je crois je crois c'est une atteinte
à la vie humaine
si on ne prend pas ses responsabilités
là sur les autres mesures que qui
étaient importantes
le pnr qu'est ce que c'est c'est de
pouvoir surveiller tracer tous les
individus considérés comme dangereux au
sein de toute l'union européenne
avant nous ne pouvions pas le faire
d'ailleurs les attentats de 2015 et de
charlie hebdo démontrer quoi que par
exemple la compagne d'un des terroristes
étaient partis en espagne vivent en
syrie via l'espagne
mais on n'avait pas de traçabilité
heureusement que nous avions de
coopération avec l'espagne pouvoir
tracer
aujourd'hui nous avons fait voter contre
la gauche et le centre le contre
l'extrême droite
cette mesure prier aujourd'hui peut
porter ses fruits puisque nouveau arrive
on a effectivement mieux tracer ces
individus dangereux sur je voudrais
juste faire un point et je termine sur
l'accord migratoire même si parce que
ses récents on nous dit il faut des
camps fermés sur sur nos territoires
macron a dit pas chez nous l'italie a
dit pas chez nous puisque mais le sujet
c'est pas les cons c'est la durée de de
rétention vous savez qu'en allemagne on
retient les étrangers en situation
illégale
plus de 18 mois en moyenne en angleterre
c'est illimité
pourquoi parce que la plupart de ces
migrants quand ils viennent sur le
territoire européen où tu donnes une
mauvaise nationalité ou jettent leurs
papiers et ils attendent déjà des années
ils sont déboutés de tout droit d'asile
ou autre chose
ils attendent ils font des enfants et
ils demandent une régularisation
l'angleterre ne les remets pas dehors
tant que vous n'avez pas sorti vos
papiers on ne vous remets pas dehors un
moment donné il accepte ou de retourner
dans leur pays ou en tous les cas de
donner leur vraie identité
et là il ya une pression sur les pays
d'origine pour avoir des laissez passer
par exemple le mali
nous avons nos soldats au mali nous
agissons pour leur sécurité ils ne
donnent pas laisser passer consulaire
pour expulser leurs ressortissants ça
n'est quand même pas acceptable comme
disait nadine il faut conditionner
l'aide qu'on leur donne au fait qui
donne des laissez-passer à leurs
ressortissants pour qu'ils reprennent
quand ils sont en situation illégale et
la dernière chose faut savoir que quand
il ya débouté par exemple en italie si
quelqu'un est refusé au titre du de
l'asile ou s'il est refusé au titre
d'une carte de séjour
il vient en france et y refait la
demande au bout de six mois et donc nous
nous exigeons qu'une décision prise dans
un état soit opposable valable pour
toute l'europe
ainsi on aura peut-être plus efficacité
pour expulser les étrangers bien merci
merci mais mes chers collègues merci à
l'ensemble des intervenants
je voudrais vous dire merci à vous mes
chers amis nous avons besoin de vous
pour relever ces défis de cette europe
qui se construit dès aujourd'hui notre
action vous l'avez vu depuis 2014 a été
intense mais j'allais dire nous avons
des marges de progrès les enjeux et les
priorités sont claires il faut enfin
adapté l'europe à la mondialisation du
21e siècle sans utopie sans rêve mais
avec détermination et conviction
nous allons avec vous pour vous faire
face honey cette europe de la protection
c'est la tête de nos concitoyens mais
j'allais dire c'est surtout notre devoir
merci à toutes et tous